c'est un soir de fête à quelques jours
du nouvel an
le DJ c'est nul autre que sergue et
Pouchkine un des plus branchés de Moscou
les convives sont aussi presque tous des
expatriés si bien qu'on se croirait dans
un club up de la capitale russe
nous sommes pourtant si loin à plus de
5000 km au Moyen-Orient
[Musique]
nous avons suivi Constantin et sa
famille dans le désert où il cherche un
site pour son prochain événement c'est
lui qui fait venir des talents Russes et
les DJ aux Émirats arabes
temporaire en fait à Moscou il était un
avocat respecté en droit international
il sait réinventer
persuadé que nudité de Duba et surtout
de la facilité avec laquelle il a pu
s'installer et fonder une entreprise ici
il serait au front ou encore pire
enterré
si l'Europe leur ferme la porte ici à
Dubaï les Russes sont accueillis à bras
ouverts surtout quand ils ont les moyens
de leur ambition
s
[Musique]
une consultante de 34 ans diplômés de
Harvard avait des clients à Londres en
Suisse et aux États-Unis ils l'ont tous
largué dès les premières bombes
[Musique]
avec ses collègues une entreprise qui
recrute des ingénieurs informatiques
russes pour le Moyen-Orient
c'est l'exode du cerveau de Russie
cancède à Liona de plus en plus
d'entrepreneurs russes relocalise leur
compagnie à Dubaï dont les banques
certes d'intermédiaires pour transférer
de l'argent de la Russie vers l'Europe
ou encore les États-Unis
de Dubaï que la majorité habite y
compris Olesia une Russe prof de langue
qui depuis le début de la guerre est
constamment sollicité par des centaines
de jeunes compatriotes qui veulent
apprendre l'anglais
et dans les faits Dubaï profite
pleinement de la guerre en Ukraine
la décision du plus riche Emirat de
rester neutre de ne pas se joindre au
concert de sanctions contre la Russie et
payante mais il lui a aussi valu de
nombreuses critiques
car c'est ici que les oligarques et les
amis du régime de Vladimir Poutine ont
transféré leur fortune ou leur yak
durant les premiers mois de la guerre
grâce à la clémence des loisirs les
ventes immobilières en 2022 ont même
atteint un record historique et c'est en
grande partie grâce aux Russes qui
investissent à coup de millions dans les
villas et les condos de luxe mais ces
oligarques ne représentent qu'une toute
petite minorité explique Vladimir
il est un agent immobilier venu de
Moscou au mois de février pour explorer
le marché et il n'est jamais reparti
[Musique]
un autre quartier prisé par les familles
russes de jeunes professionnels surtout
en quête de stabilité économique dans
certains secteurs il est même impossible
de faire quelques pas sans se faire
offrir d'acheter une propriété et on
nous dit que toutes les devises sont
acceptées en commençant par la crypto
monnaie
[Musique]
qui a quitté la Russie l'été dernier
avec sa femme Milla mais ils n'ont pas
les moyens d'acheter ces placements en
Europe sont gelés même si lui n'est pas
sanctionné
[Musique]
il travaille pour une start-up de
Londres mais vivre à Dubaï lui permet de
gérer la division russe de la compagnie
sans aucun problème
[Musique]
Dubaï avec tous ces paradoxes le leur
offre sur un plateau d'argent
on avance et on ne regarde plus en
arrière
[Musique]